foreign
[Music]
do you deal with monotonous
time-consuming administrative tasks that
come with certificate management well
you're not alone and until now issuance
and renewals of private certificates had
to be manually managed come along as we
explore how certificate Authority
service and certificate Manager work
together to simplify this process for
you managing the life cycle of your
private certificates for workloads like
Mutual TLS or private pki isn't always a
walk in the park
even when they're centralized you still
have to deal with manually issuing and
provisioning your private certificates
to your load balancers and you have to
consider all of this before your
certificates expire and renewals come up
the good news is you don't have to do it
all manually when using Cas with
certificate manager now you can have
your private certificates fully managed
by certificate manager CCM with Cas CA
pools issuing the certificates when
using this combo certificates are
automatically issued and provisioned to
your load balancer and renewed without
you needing to keep track or manually
manage that renewal this is how it works
Cas houses the ca pool that issues the
certificates CCM gives you fine control
over the issuance and provisioning of
certificates to your load balancers
without manual intervention
you can configure the managed
certificate resource with the load
balancer once and then certificate
manager takes care of issuing new
certificates and provisioning them to
the load balancer according to your
configuration plus everything is
centralized so you have one place to
manage your certificates across your
Google services
this allows you to manage and serve
larger numbers of certificates and
therefore put time and resources towards
more pressing tasks like managing your
business there are four easy steps to
provision and deploy certificates from
Cas make sure you have the ca admin
compute load balancer admin and
certificate manager owner roles before
you begin
first you'll need to create a CA pool
with at least one enabled CA or use one
that you currently have then create a
certificate issuance configuration this
is where you'll specify which pool to
use to provision your certificates this
is also the time to specify other
configurable variables like certificate
lifetime renewal period and key
algorithm next create a managed
certificate this is where you can
specify that you want a Google manage
certificate which means that Google
Cloud obtains and manages them for you
and again this managed certificate will
be configured to use the casca pool you
identified in the previous configuration
step finally attach your managed
certificate to your load balancer this
step gives certificate manager the
authorization to obtain provision and
renew your certificates to your load
balancer CCM will request the actual
certificates from Cas and provision them
to the load balancer once you do these
steps your private certificate
management is taken care of for you and
you no longer have to worry about
renewals if you'd like to know more
about having your certificates fully
managed with CCM and Cas check out the
links listed in the description below if
you enjoyed the video give us a like and
let us know your thoughts in the
comments until next time thanks for
watching
[Music]
thank you